congratulations on this it's a lot of
fun you're you're singing in this one
look at this sing and dance it was great
how did it feel was it fun it was a lot
more fun absolutely what was the prep
like for that well the prep was the best
part because of all the rehearsals and
working with a voice coach and finding
my voice and learning the the lyrics and
all of that and
to me I mean you look back at the
experience and that was the best part
yeah I'm hearing about like cast karaoke
sessions with Adina and everybody were
you in on that I was not in on that I'm
glad they had it we were really kind of
uh unfortunately locked down through
most of the shoot so they didn't really
like us being out and about too much
yeah were your kids young enough to
enjoy the first one and were they still
jazzed about this one or were they too
old this is like out of their demo now
am I the boys we found out uh during the
course of the the first movie that my
wife was pregnant with the twins so that
was halfway through the shoot and then
my daughter was a few years old at the
time so
it would be interesting to see what they
think they haven't seen it yet so and
the last time we watched the original
movie
they couldn't figure out how I got
inside the screen they kept looking at
the screen and then looking at me trying
to figure out what was going on that's
how long ago it was have they watched
any of your stuff no they don't really
watch anything I do it's it's too much
for them
[Music]